[Music]
in butwhy news okay but okay okay okay
hair always dogs now in what oh [ __ ]
dude that was the saddest line oh yeah
it is
hey panel right what's the speech movie
with to know all the artists cuz bet on
the saddest line in that movies when the
aliens like finds out that he's been
lied to and he's like but what movie is
that I thought you said space which I'm
Alan I saw everybody remember that I
like that but where did you bridge that
thought because it was just that that
was a sort of sad line okay he's like
why and he's too innocent to understand
I remember that he doesn't understand
lies I think the TV show is really real
they're an alien race and I think this
TV show is real it's like a Star Trek
and so they build a spaceship exactly
like the show and they capture those
people to help them fight this alien
space war and they're like we built the
spaceship exactly like the show so that
you'll know how to steer the ship
alright vidiian over the show they're
like exactly like home it's like three
amigos so they have to pretend that they
know how to fight this alien space war
and it's really good that's really
genius moving yeah submitted by
microphone check microphone check up
check one two check your mic check check
check
a man who recently bought an eight
million dollar island was arrested for
stealing three hundred dollars from
Kmart no Kmart was still around like
Kmart we'll find you if you stole three
hundred camera that's a big deal Jesus
all the cash that was made it came there
like that's a week of earnings for us
there's like one came our knowledge dude
it's brutal
it's like what's-her-name the
Beetlejuice girl she's she's a klepto
yeah Wynonna but stranger things again
no no right it yeah she's back stranger
things brought it back oh she was she
was a klepto yeah she's relaxed fit it's
about the thrill of of stealing she's
paying for life that's this you can look
outside but she can't go in her
territory stranger things I don't know
she's acting like she's so good yeah
is that like maniac mom yeah yeah she
freaking under the bus dude all 18
wheels I do that to him I that I can't
even so it's things that your you don't
like about you
yeah yeah projected it I'm projecting
for sure because I hate I do that
I can't hear whistling which I've never
heard you whistle talk Oh me and Geo do
it all the time
guys do it for fun no no ill cuz I've
never noticed you to do that but there
are people that do that
what kind of was so I'm listening for
like a train whistle here dude that's
like clicky clicky Spiti radio voice I
turn that [ __ ] off man I hear that every
time we get together for a group photo
cuz Joe and I point this out to you that
you're the now hear them so you don't
like ASL man I hate you might like soap
curl crunching though man oh it's so
good Nikki's inside what's going on with
this game oh yeah I need to know why he
stole from Kmart now Johnson crunching
you million I wanted a million dollar
[ __ ] Island okay okay guys it's like
all these curls that are hardened and
then she crunches them in just the right
way where is she right now yes potato
chip bags
yes soap curls so it's so what is so
they Utley like shave soap and corals
like with the G scraper wait for it to
get all that soap mm-hmm but gets hard
in a certain way where it crunches like
Pringles or Doritos or whatever oh it's
like dries out yeah yeah and then they
crunch them all together and it's really
colorful and then they crunch it and
it's like woah that's a visual oh [ __ ]
like that yeah like watching cake
decorating
yeah it's like that this is why Nikki I
called Nikki my sick home wife cuz I'll
just be chillin at home and then she
comes in my office and she's like hey do
you have a bar soap and then she doesn't
say what the [ __ ] going on
and then later on I just see on the
kitchen sink there's like a great enough
[ __ ] thing to bar so what happened and
then yeah and then she's like
frustrating her office she's like it
doesn't work and I like what doesn't
work I don't know anything that's going
on I'm like Ricky and I come home I have
no idea what she's up to
it's real we wanted to write a series
that was like like similar to that with
our dynamic because I just do different
sick home everyday is a new episode of
the show and it's like a grasshopper
facial how come you stole video right
now and then they hear the story about
but I actually care about the story
that's this time and I watch it I love
it if he's interested I'm just like
hurry up
I can hear just inside the camera now
she's a cop [ __ ] you Joe so let me
please Joe and tell you this thank you
better be the best toy ever now more
interesting it's so curly he's gonna be
disappointed all right that's all right
back yeah we'll go break that cuz I need
to know more this guy did it
59 years old Wow I just want to know how
he got eight million that's the white
people face
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
Island zoo with the quarry on it look
like a military like [ __ ] Fortuna Key
West and so he bought this for eight
million right yeah and then he got
caught for stealing three hundred
dollars worth of goods from Oh what the
local Kmart so what happened what I
thought he spoke to go into dollars
period yeah yeah Kmart to rack up three
hundred bucks
he had an 18-wheeler in there he
actually purchased these items and then
he returned them like he had he kept the
boxes he put other [ __ ] inside like
for example for a coffee maker he put in
a basket ball inside the oh so he just
likes to [ __ ] around what so he's bored
so thank you tells that he tells the cop
like whoa I mean it was a cashier spot
why she couldn't like they couldn't
figure out that the weight was off he's
like oh you think you're mad like oh I
wanted a coffee maker and there was a
basketball in there that's good can make
coffee with this basket what you do is
you steal the coffee maker then you
return it and get the money for it yes
that's how you steal that's how you
money launderers good girlfriend return
things without the receipt he did get
another coffee maker and then he
returned it when they used one Amy's
like he just switched it out for a new
one you know what they did I used to
work at Target right most people what
they do is they'll open up the [ __ ]
you know the the stroller the baby
stroller you he and then they load up
that [ __ ] with whatever they want and
then they tape it back up
and then they just buy the stroller
that's smart as far cuz nobody like take
check to see how much it weighs no no
that's that's good okay
should Americans steal in there but then
you bought a straw and you filled it was
like what cans of beans turn the
stroller and it's scot-free victimless
crime smart that's why they actually cuz
I used to work at Babies R Us for like
three months and they told us to
actually open the box to look inside
really did you ever catch people one
time would you even care about when you
work there like me that's why they have
the theft department they have their own
security Elbridge in they call yeah hell
yeah
LP loss prevention you know they can't
arrest you know like they say can you
they have to ask for your permission
it's like a citizen's around yeah they
can't even they can't even like force
you they have to say hey can you come
with us and what happens is most people
are so scared of people in positions of
power they just go you if you say no I
can't I'm not coming and you walk out
they can't even touch you don't let them
know everybody's gonna know wait I want
people to stay it's the same [ __ ] as a
citizen or to anthropology and you only
follow them so far outside the store so
they just keep booking it like you're
you can't like you can't do anything you
can't touch but did you really respect
that boundary we like walk up to this
boundary no no no I just don't like
confrontation I just got put there cuz
that was the station I was put at but I
don't like confrontation that saying
would go off all the time I didn't can I
look at your okay no all right well I
was like I was like stealing is wrong
theft is wrong I will be a hero someday
and then now I'm at my own grocery store
and I see people just open the
handicapped thing and walk out with
hands full of [ __ ] I'm like good for you
why were you such a Boy Scout I have no
idea that's like you watch superhero
movies as a can you like do you watch
Batman and [ __ ] you think'll at all I
want to be a good person and [ __ ] yeah
but I'm like good for these people
that's all a five-cent now a later one
time from a gas station I felt so bad
the guilt ate me alive like and could
never steal again
really I actually saw a toothbrush a
couple years ago from a grocery store
cuz I was on the phone while I liked
talking about movie ideas home alone
while I was holding a toothbrush I just
walked out exactly no a nice tall
toothbrush - of all things and then now
every time I go to the exactly that
grocery store I'm like I walk through
like I'm holding a [ __ ] cross I
[ __ ] you guys I'm so sorry
one toothbrush who cuz then I got a cop
do it yeah it's too late now cop to it
here's here's actually limitation it was
warning Cena barber to because I was
visiting Nikki's phone so he's like hey
years ago I sold two three so here's an
extra three bucks the laugh at me okay I
guess she doesn't care it's like Tim was
gonna kids are Russian don't give a [ __ ]
when I worked at Target right they have
these cameras it's pretty crazy so you
could zoom in all the way into the
parking lot and get their license plate
yeah over it so our security never ran
after or did anything to just be like
stopping and if they keep walking they
just go all right they're going outside
and then they just get the camera and
they go you can't go to your car
immediately you just keep walking into
you're out of you then you gotta come
back later get your car this is how you
steal people listen to us we want you
that's a handicap thing I'm telling you
just open up your gate and [ __ ] walk
right out the front door do it at a mall
you're not hurt you could do what my
friend did and he would just take up
like two years you would just get like
big boxes of TV or whatever they'll go
to the customer return center and be
like can I return this they're like oh
do you have the receipt oh I left it in
my car yeah dude what the end of mall I
need to take the TV with you so they go
right from the aisle with the TV to the
customers out return and then they're
like oh [ __ ] let me go take yeah that's
been the end of malls is gonna be the
end of me being able to hang with my
family and doing [ __ ] balls that's like
it yeah dude other than just sitting in
the [ __ ] room like to go to the mall
steal I don't know no we just go to the
mall and walk around and [ __ ] then we go
to different stores so what do they do
there San Diego there's no any cool
things are doing yeah you would you
think but not my family they don't want
to do anything they go there to like
feel the AC cuz I know a lot of people
do that well yeah dude there's go they
can walk the 400 people go to walk the
mall before it even opens because it's
safe but the worst thing is they want to
walk with you to every store but then
they don't even go in the stores just
wait outside and then use this thing
pick up with you after that it smells
like
shoot in there too cuz like I don't know
what they do they don't change diapers
in the kids area or something but it
smells like garbage in Santa Barbara
there's no indoor malls it's all outdoor
and I never knew them indoor malls could
smell that bad you need to go to the
dell'Amore the Galleria yeah please
don't end malls man I will have nothing
to do my [ __ ] family's gonna get so
bored with the beat go to a park mall we
went to with the VR thing yeah Century
City Mall oh yeah I would do that that's
a good mall
[Music]